[Music]
benefiting from the presence of deandre
hopkins aj green rondelle moore
christian kirk
is kyle murray who coincidentally comes
in
at number seven
on the chris sims
top 40 quarterback
countdown
there he is kyler murray the guy who
still would like to play both baseball
and football but for now it's football
only and he enters year three pivotal
year for any player any player that
that's going to reach the proverbial
next level what's he learned in two
years can he pivot can he adjust can
cliff kingsbury i almost put cliff
kingsbury in the no excuses draft
yesterday
because you got kyle murray you got aj
green you got deandre hopkins
this is year three for kingsbury two
he's gonna be the one who's responsible
for kyla murray but you know murray i
think is on the precipice of being one
of the greats clearly you got him at
number seven yeah you think he is how
great can he be yeah he can be top three
top two the number one quarterback in
football i mean he's special he's one of
the the biggest weapons we have at the
position in all of the sport you know
it's rare he's kind of a polished passer
let alone he's as fast as lamar jackson
running the ball in fact if you give me
the first 20 yards of a race i think i'm
taking kyla murray over lamar jackson i
don't know if there's any player
that has more of an effect
on the success of their team's offense
maybe than kyler murray now we have some
guys that are coming up you know later
in the show maybe we could argue that
point but but my point with murray is he
himself
is made that offense there are top 10
rushing offense they have no business
being there there are top 10 rushing
offense not because they blow people off
the line of scrimmage or do anything
like that because kyla murray they're
running so you have to worry about
defending that first right that's the
first thing and his ability to keep the
ball and get around the edge i don't
care who you are deion sanders whatever
it's scary i mean look at he he rips off
30-yard runs quicker than anybody i've
ever seen and this is part of what you
have to do to defend him let alone he's
a good passer so now you have to go wait
we got to play some defenses to worry
about what he can do on re-option let
alone you have to worry about when he
drops back to pass and just scrambles
like this one right here oh nobody's
open moving around the pocket great
presence people are down the field there
so the field's spread out all he had to
do was make one guy miss and he gets a
20 yard gain here's the same thing
remember this week one last year i mean
what who is this the tasmanian devil or
kyler murray i mean it's insane what he
does he's really special that way and
then
he has
a special arm that goes with it and you
know last year we saw a little he he
kind of told us that he was a little
beat up at one p at one point during the
year and not throwing the ball the way
he wanted but that's where he's really
special is you don't have to have a
totally complicated formula spread the
field give him some concepts and if
they're open he'll hit him and if
nothing's there he'll make a play but
he's got he has a powerful arm i mean
remember last year when deandre hopkins
got there mike one of the first things
he said was i can't get over the pop and
kyla murray's the ball when he throws it
i mean 20 yard outs no problem you know
deep post go rouse he can do all of that
stuff with ease they in my opinion just
need to open up that offense a little
bit more it's a little predictable
you've heard me say that but man he's a
special football player and i think
they're on the right path for finding
the right personnel and formula
to play that makes sense for them
and for for this guy i mean you know how
do you stop that running to the left
awkward patrick mahomes type throw he
recognizes the defenders not looking so
he could throw the ball because he knows
that guy's not going to be able to play
the ball and he puts it in the perfect
spot really really special talent and
really well-rounded in just about all
aspects of his game is only negative
mike is his size at times that affects
him in the pocket with seeing people and
every now and then he misses a guy open
down the middle of the field because he
can't see it because of his size well
also he's prone to getting injured if he
gets hit and we had seen a lot of
instances over the first two years of
his career where he
he very adeptly and adroit and
intelligently avoids contact and resists
that temptation to try to squeeze out
another couple yards i don't know how
many times i've seen that move that he
does where he squirts out of the pocket
gets down the left sideline
runs runs runs and then just as the
defender is closing in steps out of
bounds knows how to do it knows when to
slide slides sideways slides backwards
slides whatever he has to do it's smart
and what happened last year he got hit
he got hurt and it threw everything off
kilder for the arizona cardinals he
talked about that recently yeah when his
shoulder was messed up and he was more
hesitant to run they didn't have
the passing attack no
that they could take advantage of and
that was kind of a little shot
a little bit a little bit of a shot
at cliff not much of one didn't raise it
at the time but it's kind of
crystallizing now
when when
you're saying hey you take away my
ability to run and we gotta throw and we
can't well it's not because calamari
can't throw it that's right that's for
damn sure that's right because they
aren't drawing up the plays to let him
throw it that that's it mike that that
to me and you know kingsbury he's still
getting used to the nfl he's made
strides in each year as far as i went oh
the offense got a little bit better but
there does have to be more there's got
to be more
you know formations personnel sets
and to me i i think you're doing an
injustice of the team by always putting
kyler murray in the shotgun and
everything like that you know we've had
these conversations with other
quarterbacks put them underneath the
center like they're going to do in
baltimore or lamar jackson it creates
more of a mesh it's harder to see him
behind the line of scrimmage what he's
doing with the ball is he going this way
that way you don't know you know there
just has to be more variety in the
offense and then you know last year too
you i think you'll remember this we
broke down like deandre hopkins routery
a lot of the times to to emphasize your
point more about more offense and more
creative route schemes and things like
that i mean he it's all in the same
little area it's very little variety in
what he does as far as a route runner
and that speaks to the offense that's
where you know look every throw you see
here is out route to the left sideline
deandre hopkins you know it's everything
kind of looks similar that way there's
the great hail murray that was
unbelievable play and catch and all of
that but yeah there's a little bit too
much of a predictability to the drop
back pass offense and they wouldn't get
away with it if they didn't have kyla
murray at quarterback and that's where
the offense has to change and and help
him out a little bit more
they didn't handle that moment well they
were two and six after that game right
two and six from six and three
to two and five excuse me i want to get
my facts straight two and five over the
final seven after that game it's almost
like they that that was the crowning
moment of their season we've arrived
we're here and it all just kind of fell
apart after that the injury had
something to do with the short week
turnaround with the seahawks that's when
the injury first became obvious he had
told us he'd already injured that
shoulder but it really caught up with
him that night look at that the last
seven games a major drop in passing an
obvious and clear drop in rushing from
67 yards per game all the way down to
30.7 10 rushing touchdowns
down to one they'd use him in in goal
line situations around the ball not like
cam newton slam into the line or go up
and over just squirt out no one can
catch you and chris that's got to make
it hard for cliff kingsbury
to even have the incentive to develop
the full and complete offense because
you don't need it there's a little of
them a homes quality there where ah okay
well this is the play but yeah no doubt
no doubt you're right he'll make it work
you're right yeah we don't we don't need
to have a bunch of fancy schmancy plays
in our playbook we got kyler murray yeah
there is part of that for sure you know
you just have to do it the right way to
where it doesn't have to be overly
complicated you just got to do it in a
way that really stresses the defense and
really puts them in a bind and i think
that's the big thing they just have to
find that that right formula for kyla
murray and whatever that is
but but i don't think there's any doubt
he's a special football player he can do
everything that we talk about all the
time whether it's he takes advantage of
what the offense has there but like you
say all the time too play breaks down or
teams bad or whatever
he can make it all happen he can make
chicken salad out of chicken you know
what a lot he really can so no i don't
know what you're referring to i know
well i'll say it if you don't know
but but yeah that's where he's a special
special quarterback and really
the value of him and again the stats
can't really quantify how great he is
yeah the passing numbers are good
819 yards rushing right 11 touchdowns to
go along with that the pressure he puts
on a defense and like i said if they can
just grow the offense or find a few more
ways to stress defenses out make the
game a little easier for kylie murray
arizona could be a handful this year for
the nfc west and the
nfc and they have one more season during
which they can enjoy the reduced
relative to a franchise quarterback on a
second contract pay that kyler murray
gets after this year it's going to be
time for michael bidwell to come up with
the big money for kyla murray i suspect
he's not going to want to wait around
for after four years or five years to
get his financial reward
and chris look i'm calling it now yeah
if they don't make the playoffs this
year with kyler murray they're going to
have a new coach next year i i would i
would bet that and it's not an
indictment of cliff kingsbury as much as
it's a recognition of how the cardinals
have handled their business
they and i remember when when i i used
to get the record and fact book remember
we had fun with mad dog about that at
the super bowl the little phone book
that they that they print
and when you for every team there's
three four pages of information and it
shows for every franchise their history
of coaches and for the cardinals that
law that column goes on and on and on
and on i mean they chew them up and they
spit them out and they are not patient
with their head coaches and i think
three years of no playoffs for cliff
kingsbury it's going to be a far
different experience than three years of
no playoffs for john gruden yeah yeah it
is i think you know
you know you said it already the no
excuse draft those type of things hey
they've done some good things in free
agency
we'll see if some of these draft picks
work out i mean they're dealing they're
they're first rounders even collins he
just got in trouble for speeding in the
car whatever else but like they've
certainly improved the team so that
they're definitely going to put a little
bit more pressure on on cliff kingsbury
and to see what he can do with you know
with them as uh
totally as a as a football team it's a
tough division i don't know i don't know
if i could sit here right now and pick
them to go to the nfc playoffs with that
division they're in right now i kind of
got to see it to believe it i think
they could be improved significantly
over last year and still finish in
fourth place
in that division it's unfortunate that
that they're stuck there uh but they are
let's take a break i mentioned kyler
murray has one year to go until he's
eligible to get paid
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports